في سبتمبر من عام 2022 سجل تسريب للغاز في
مياه بحر البلطيق في ثلاثه مواضع مختلفه
من خط انابيب نور ستريم وفقا للحكومتين
السويديه والدنماركيه فماذا حدث بالضبط خط
انابيب او السيل الشمالي وخط انابيب مزدوج
يتجاوز طوله 1200 كيلومتر وينقل الغاز
مباشره من روسيا الى المانيا عبر بحر
البلطيق وهو اطول خط انابيب تحت مياه
البحر توقفت الامدادات عبر النوت ستريم
واحد منذ نهايه اغسطس الماضي لاجراء
عمليات الصيانه لكن خط الانابيب لم يستانف
عملياته ليله السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر
الماضي رصد انخفاض غير متوقع وسريع في
الضغط في خط نورس في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الدنماركيه الخاصه جنوب شرقي بورن هولم
وتقع بين الساحل الجنوبي من السويد
وبولندا
في اليوم الموالي رصد تسريبان اخران في
الشمال الشرقي من جزيره بورن هولم في خط
انابيب نورت ستريم واحد الذي لا يعمل
ولكنه يحتوي على الغاز ووقع احد التسربين
في المياه السويديه والاخر في المياه
الدنماركيه
[موسيقى]